you posted an instagram that caught some
attention can we set the record straight
were we throwing shade megan fox's way i
don't know how to throw
shade subtly it was honestly
just like my mother took a picture of me
i was standing next to the poster she
said let me grab a picture
before i went into the premiere i did a
quick like i'm excited
and posted it and and i know how this
works
it makes a much more intriguing headline
to see
lala kent tries to shade megan fox
rather than
lala's mom takes a picture of her next
to you know randall's
poster so no i was i i really enjoy
megan we've had
amazing times together you know i got my
tattoo that says rand
with megan and mgk so i would never
throw shade at her
no i wish it was more i wish it was more
interesting but that's really the story
it's kind of like the pasta
right it's not about the pasta
right it's like it's one thing the media
turns it into another
but hey people are talking about the
movie so
right i'll press
that's how you have to look at it or
it'll eat you alive
yeah and i actually saw right before
this uh megan
somebody asked her about it and she was
like no lala's a good chick she would
not do that
oh good that was the first thing because
i actually didn't know that it had
become a thing
until randall told me this is a thing
and i was like god damn it like you
really have to be careful of
every single thing that you post because
anything can come across
as something completely different right
and i because people were also then
reading and you were celebrating
everybody who showed up for the premiere
and obviously megan and coulson um and
bruce didn't
out of covert concern right and it
wasn't like
i think people were just reading people
love to make drama as you well know
you know i am the first person to say if
you have a coded concern you should stay
home especially me being a new mom
i also had those same concerns so
i in no way was thinking like you should
have shown up
i completely understand safety is is the
most important thing
listen i don't know what you think you
saw but i'm a copper right
i ain't gonna hurt you lala this is rare
we're usually not talking about lala the
actress but here we are today because
out of death is out for people to watch
not
the la la we know you are playing
not only a cop but spoiler alert
a dirty cop i love it and that's the one
thing that i was like
so drawn to this because i've never
played a dirty cop before
i've played a lot of things but that has
not been one look what's your plan
what was it like to tap into that
because it is pared down
it's dirty it's grimy you've got a
southern accent going on
it was a lot of fun um
the southern accent i tried to speak in
a southern accent for a while because
accents are not my strong point which
was another reason why i loved it
because i like anything that challenges
me
and i was five months pregnant when we
were filming this so i've
i've never been a diva on set ever
except for this film
i was hormonally raging at times
luckily the director was like very chill
with me and allowed me
to go through my process but i i really
did have a great
time so this is technically baby ocean's
big screen debut it really is i mean
she's definitely a star on vanderpump
rules but this was like
her her first you know on camera
appearance
and she plays the part great you don't
even know she's there just slips right
into the scenes
oh my gosh bryce can i tell you the
second we rapped i got back to la and
suddenly i just like was showing
it was crazy she's a professional
her timing's impeccable i will say like
when we film vanderpump they're only
allowed to film for 20 minutes just
because of their age
and she could be a terror
and the second she knows she's on camera
she calms herself
down and then when she's wrapped she's
like back to screaming her head off
she's a professional
born for it and you can trust me what we
need is evidence
you get to act opposite a film
legend bruce willis how intimidating is
that
i've been lucky enough to have
played opposite of bruce willis a
handful of times before and
i'm telling you it doesn't even matter
if i had done it a million times before
the second he shows up on set i forget
my own name because he's a legend
like i show up and i'm like i'm la la
kent and then he shows up and i'm like
that's bruce willis
like you are lauren from utah right now
and
it's bruce willis you know it's very
intimidating
what happened she assaulted me she's
some sort of junkie
do you feel like you get taken seriously
as an actor
i don't feel like i get taken seriously
as
really anything that i try to break into
and
and i'm okay with that i knew the second
that i signed on for vanderpump rules
that
i would put myself into a box
i knew that it would bring a lot of
opportunity but i knew
that it would also be really hard for me
to break
out of the box and my
hope is just that people watch anything
that i'm
in as far as you know films that i have
been working on this craft since i was
12 years old i didn't move to la to be
on vanderpump rules i moved to la to be
an actress so
no matter what the feedback is i will
continue to work on that craft and try
my best to give a great performance
what's the dream role the dream project
in terms of acting
oh i i would love to be in a comedy
i would love to be in an apatow film
because i think he's just a creative
genius and
just the way he presents comedy
in a film is is brilliant so i think
that that would be my dream
okay well put it out there in the
universe the universe
you work a lot in
your man randall's films yes um
and i think people have a preconceived
notion that he's just like
giving these opportunities to you what
do you say to people who are like
questioning this creative partnership if
you will
yeah well i would think the same thing
if i were an outsider i'd be like well
how easy is this she just gets to be put
in every film
um for people who don't understand i
have to be approved by the studio
before i'm in any of randall's films
when i first acted in one of randall's
films which was
opposite bruce willis i then had proven
myself to go
on to you know being okayed for other
roles like this
when it came to al pacino you know not
only did the
studio have to approve me but al pacino
had to approve me as well
it wasn't just handed to me so it it's
almost more intimidating
and a different kind of rejection
because
you know if i say to randall i really
want this part and then i don't
get it it's like you couldn't fight hard
enough for me
but it just goes so far beyond randall i
wish it was that easy because then i
feel like i
would be in a lot more but
i definitely like the al pacino film i
had to audition for
this bruce willis film you know i had
proven myself and and i
feel very proud of that
you